so you get given this theory see the
flesh angle I see that's easy to get is
this one over here angle staying on the
same oh that's gotta be 38 now
alternatively the next easiest one or
maybe the equal easiest one is that this
38 and this 38 are alternate angles on
parallel lines please indicate paralyze
we see how reason man I don't know what
they called them parallel and then
lastly you can either go from either of
these up to here again for the same
reason if I work from here to here to be
alternate angles if I were communicating
to be able to say no the same up okay
papi here we go
I've got a hundred fifty degrees up in
the top what can I do with that a
hundred fifty degrees yeah we can on the
opposite corner that's got to be 65
because opposite air goes in a cyclic
quadrilateral are supplementary okay
once you've got that 65 is trivial from
there because you've got that saucily
triangle so I think this is your unknown
so two K plus 65 that'll give you the
angle sum of triangle and my answers
picture sent the half right and last
second so true okay again you've got a
variety of things that you can see
immediately but so for starters this
value here got to be right straight away
because you Dre this is a diameter B is
equal to 90 degrees reason to say be
separation writing you toss everything
what else can I do
where else would you go okay I could say
here this is the angle between the
tangent and the court and should be able
in the alternate segment that's formed
by that court must be the same as the
angle between the tension
and right that's that's also going to
work or and then you've got your last
one here you can either go angles of a
triangle because I have the other two
angles now or alternatively
alternatively the tangent attention is
perpendicular to the radius at the point
of contact so this must be the
complement of 58 which is 32 now have a
look at the question what they give you
now I have said before this guy here
right what is PQ what kind of a line is
it I hate to call it but more
specifically what kinda what's special
about this coin it's what I know that it
is perpendicular to the tangent I think
it's abnormal okay and I hope you
instantly should recognize that because
you see this formula that's the this is
the whole reason why I gave in those
folders not see you could quit them but
you can recognize them right so that's
the normal and then they say prove that
this is true okay now as I mentioned
before they'll kill you do not they say
do not prove it
as we Sisson lucky you they've handed to
you if they did not stay his line you
would need to derive that it's not hard
I can just take the McGrady to the point
you take the negative reciprocal and off
you go
it's not hard to get anybody but they're
headed to you that's nice I think right
now you look at it for a second with me
clearly this is going to be our starting
point right like this is what I know
about this situation then don't you know
very much else so won't you begin from
here now I'm going to begin from here
and I'm somehow gonna get two Kia G
notice this one he has the prettier
paint in it that should make sense
because define is the normal at people
right but this is cute enough how did it
get cuter small territory profession
how'd it get cute because because it's
not just a normal it's like you told me
a quart
it has to go through Q so therefore my
first line says see it's cute wise on
picture like by definition because it's
P Q write the equation to pick you
satisfied by the coordinates of Q you
see that you see I'm taking these and
they should work in this equation but
that's all I've done taking queue up
substituted here so here is where I saw
X so I'm substituting into a queue and
here is where I saw why there's a py
there so that becomes P and Q squared X
Q squared is the y-coordinate okay now
from here it's just a bit of algebra
honestly I know what I'm starting with
I know where I'm going okay so I can see
how am I gonna get rid of well there's
no names that's easy to get rid of what
I do at the age I divide through by a
because every single term in my um
expression here in the thick side has
eight it's like by the truth that looks
good
I noticed I've got a P cubed here but
don't pee cubes up here in the result
trying to get to you so what does that
imply to you I'm gonna have to do some
factorize e and therefore subdivision
some canceling because I can't leave
that PQ flying around so when I do this
I can see pretty quickly I've got two of
these right to Q and a minus two P so
that's easy to factorize and what I'm
left with it also has a common factor
namely what's the common factor yet it's
me isn't it which is exactly what I
wanted to get rid of the P cube okay so
I get my to of this by none of this once
I see I've got some factorization
Happiny the difference of squares
becomes an obvious next step because I
need to cancel out that humans can now
both its main point but why can I can't
talk to you guys Pete it's written down
right because P and Q are at the same
point the company the same point right
by definition came to a different spot
so therefore Q minus P is zero therefore
I could divide by it once I've divided
by it on there like I just
of re-expand how do you have your pal
good that much when I briefly explained
what was your approach you mean the
gradient I mean good yeah so the
gradient Oh the tangent is just yeah
okay so very good so what is he just
stop there because you've actually said
something of occlusion that where is he
getting for that problem
how does he know the gradient of this
son boy is that good because my
definition and admittedly you might
actually have to do a little bit of work
to get there you may have to you set a
grading formula right but we know that
the equation of this chord like we've
we've rehearse this before is y equals
half P plus 2x and minus minus is a P P
okay because I can see their grade right
and we think could it what that actually
means is it's the average of the
gradient of paint and the gradient of
cute so so you said that this is what
you say it weighs on a few hey that's
right average there and because we know
that these two if I call this M 1 and M
2 they're perpendicular by definition
right so and then you're going to go
ahead and do your work from there all
right I like that that's good
I suppose my provides them as you've got
it you've got to demonstrate that but it
doesn't take very long does it
that's what I do alright now part two
again another show okay if the court
appeared oq are perpendicular so that
immediately tells you this like yeah
right
that's the chords are perpendicular so
that's what you can know about their
gradients I want to show the piece rate
equals two so I need to do it what these
two gradients are and they don't have to
find by finding this gradient key up you
know to finally bring you there
I don't even really need to find it
because it's exactly the same argument
which is why I say similarly okay and
then I'm just substituting it po2 times
curious 81 and how pops this which you
can sub see you back into part one may
be happy at this moment